à la une ce soir l'arrivée de manuel
maquereau en algérie une visite d'état
et d'amitié de trois jours le président
s'est entretenu avec son homologue
algérien abdelmadjid tebboune à son
arrivée à alger plusieurs dossiers sont
sur la table mais l'objectif affiché de
cette visite c'est bien le rapprochement
décryptage dans un instant avec kader
abderrahim chercheur spécialiste du
maghreb auteur de géopolitique de
l'algérie
en angola la commission nationale
électorale a donné ce jeudi des
résultats provisoires des résultats qui
mettent en tête le parti au pouvoir le
mt est là devant l'unita le parti
historique d'opposition mais l'écart
entre les deux formations est serré le
parti d'opposition conteste ces premiers
résultats les détails dans ce journal
les violences postélectorales dénoncé
par des membres de la commission
électorale au kenya ils se sont réunis
devant leur bureau à naïrobi venus de
nombreuses régions différentes ce sont
eux qui ont été en première ligne lors
de ces violences messieurs seront
anaérobie dans cette édition
[Musique]
on va donc commencer par la visite du
chef de l'état emmanuel macron en
algérie il a été question évidemment de
rapprochement une visite d'amitié le
chef de l'état est arrivé à alger en
début d'après midi avec une délégation
de 90 personnes accompagné de sept
ministres il s'est ensuite rendu au
mémorial des martyrs déposé une gerbe de
fleurs un geste symbolique en ce 60e
anniversaire de l'indépendance de
l'algérie il s'est ensuite entretenu
avec le chef de l'état algérien des
matchs des bonnes et ils se sont tous
les deux exprimé je vous propose
d'écouter emmanuel macron
nous avons un passé commun il est
complexe douloureux
et
il a plu parfois comme empêcher de
regarder l'avenir nous vivons je ne
crois un moment unique qui je l'espère
doit nous permettre de regarder en face
ce passé avec beaucoup d'humilité
volonté de vérité de
mémoire et d'histoire
kader abderrahim chercheur maître de
conférences à sciences po et auteur du
livre géopolitique de l'algérie entre
autres est notre invité ce soir bonsoir
kader abderrahim merci d'être avec nous
alors cette visite officielle revêtait
un caractère particulier ou
s'inscrit-elle dans la continuité des
visites des chefs d'état français
visiblement on est en train d'assister à
un tourment puisque le prénom d'albi
vient d'annoncer lui-même la la création
d'une commission mixte d'historiens
algériens et français donc on est à la
fois dans la continuité de relations
diplomatiques qui sont très forts très
forte et en même temps
il semblerait qu'on assiste à un
tournant après la visite de benjamin
stora début juillet à alger et l
audience que lui a accordée le président
algérien c'est une demi surprise
il est bien que les choses aillent dans
ce sens si je peux me permettre un un
jugement maintenant il ya quand même
beaucoup d'autres dossiers qui ont été
peu abordée peu évoquée par le président
de la république et qui le seront sans
doute notamment je pense ici à la
question des visas à la question
énergétique à la question des visas
consulaires concernant les les immigrés
clandestins algériens ou les
délinquantes qui pourrait être expulsé
donc voilà de tous ces dossiers là qui
sont sensibles qui peuvent faire capoter
aussi cette visite sont seront sans
doute abordée dans les entretiens en
tête à tête coraux les deux chefs d'état
alors tout le monde a en tête évidemment
la question du gaz avec la guerre en
ukraine mais est ce vraiment le gaz qui
a précipité ce rapprochement et
l'organisation de cette visite où y
avait-il d'autres urgences
il y a toujours j'ai envie de dire d
urgence concernant la relation
bilatérale singulière entre ces deux
pays qui sera toujours une relation
particulière singulière unique est à
tout point de vue d'ailleurs donc il n'y
avait peut-être pas d'urgence mais je
crois qu'il d'abord pour le présent
macron c'est un geste importante que à
peine est réélu sont l'un de ses
premiers voyages
internationaux se fassent eux en algérie
à un moment où l'algérie et brouilly
diplomatiquement avec l'espagne qu'elle
a littéralement coupé les ponts avec le
maroc que la situation au maghreb est
très inquiétante compte de ce qui se
passe notamment en libye avec laquelle
l'algérie à 1200 km de frontière commune
et puis il ya des sujets d'intérêt
commun
barca l'armée française vient de se
retirer du mali le mali c'est aussi un
sujet de préoccupation pour les
autorités algériennes alors justement
quel rôle peut jouer l'algérie dans la
crise entre la france et le mali sachant
qu alger est proche aussi de moscou
oui
pour le moment en tout cas l'algérie a
été extrêmement
discrète on sait qu'elle est très
présent depuis les années 20 des années
60 début des années 70 parce que c'est
son espace stratégique 1 c'est quand
même son flanc sud le sahara sahel donc
sécuriser sa frontière et s'assurer de
la stabilité des régimes qui l'entourent
était pour l'algérie une préoccupation
constante alors aujourd'hui nous avons
un pays la france qui vient de se
retirer dans les conditions dans
lesquelles
que l'on connaît avec le comité fait une
demi victoire je sais pas là encore où
il faut placer le curseur mais il l'est
aujourd'hui il semblerait que algériens
et français à la fois être intérêt à
travailler ensemble sur les questions de
sécurité de défense pour ce qui concerne
l'ensemble du sahel mais de ce point de
vue là la france pourrait avoir besoin
de l'algérie qui entretient de très
bonnes relations avec la junte malienne
mais également avec le président
nigériens et avec les autorités de dubaï
de ouagadougou donc voilà je crois qu'il
ya on est compte tenu du contexte de la
guerre en ukraine on est aujourd'hui à
la veille d'un nouvel ordre
international et dans cette nouvelle
géopolitique qui émerge sous nos yeux
l'algérie cherche à se placer et a
présenté son meilleur profil et la
france pourrait être un partenaire
important et utile alors l'algérie alors
vous l'avez évoqué la question du sahara
occidental elle sera elle a été déjà
traitée elle sera encore traités paris
veut apaiser la situation entre alger et
rabat paris entretient de très bonnes
relations avec le maroc donc
c'est la volonté ou de paris d'apaiser
les tensions mais que veut l'algérie est
le pays dispose t-il de moyens de
pressions diplomatiques pour tenter de
faire entendre sa voix dans ce dossier
les questions que ça rase d'un juge est
effectivement très sensée très délicat
en tous points de vue tellement sensible
d'ailleurs que les européens et
singulièrement la france ont
soigneusement évité au cours de ce demi
siècle en 1975 ou 2022 ça fait quarante
sept ans pour être précis
ont soigneusement évité de de se fâcher
ou de se brouiller avec l'un ou l'autre
même si à bruxelles et les états membres
de l'union européenne sont quand même
plutôt favorable aux thèses marocaines à
propos de l'autonomie d'une autonomie
très très importante qui pourrait être
accordée à ces territoires du sahara
maintenant effectivement la question qui
se pose c'est que veut l'algérie en tout
cas je serais bien en peine de vous de
vous répondre précisément hormis
rappeler le discours officiel du régime
algérien depuis 1975 et le début de
cette question qui empoisonne les
relations intermaghrébines
c'est à dire que l'algérie campe sur une
position de principe qui est la
souveraineté des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes donc l'algérie s'accroche à
cette idée de référendum qui avait été
lancé par le roi hassan 2 et dont on
voit et donc on sait aujourd'hui qu'il
n'aura jamais lieu et donc tout l'enjeu
est aujourd'hui de savoir qu'est-ce que
unique qu'est ce que l'on pourrait
donner en échange ou accordée à
l'algérie pour qu'elle accepte de
discuter de négocier
avec les sahraouis avec le polisario
mais également et certainement avec le
maroc donc on n'est pas à la veille du
commencement d'un début de solution je
crois que c'est un conflit qui va durer
encore est en tout cas là la médiation
dont on a parlé dans la presse et qui a
fuité ces derniers jours n'a pas encore
été annoncée et puis je crois que ce
serait peut-être une maladresse que le
président français 'l'annonce depuis
âgées ce qui pourrait froisser les
marocains merci beaucoup kader
abderrahim pour votre décryptage
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur maître
de conférences à sciences po et auteur
de géopolitique de l'algérie merci
infiniment
en angola je vous le disais tout à
l'heure la commission nationale
électorale à à dépouiller 97 % des
bulletins on va tout de suite prendre la
direction de lunda retrouver notre
envoyé spécial clemmons bonnerot clément
on est proche des résultats
oui ce sont des résultats quasiment
finaux qui ont été donnés par la
commission nationale électorale
ce jeudi soir il porte donc sur 80 un
peu plus de 97 % des bulletins de vote
dépouillés à travers le pays et ils
donnent une avance assez confortable au
mpla le parti au pouvoir depuis
l'indépendance en 1975 qui remporte 51
07 % des voix ce qui lui permettrait
d'obtenir 124 sièges sur 220 à
l'assemblée nationale mais l'unita le
principal parti d'opposition réalise un
score historique un peu plus de 44 % ce
qui l'est permettrait quasiment de
doubler son nombre de sièges à
l'assemblée nationale qui passerait de
51 à 90 sièges l'unita qui arrivent
également premier dans au moins trois
provinces et notamment dans la capitale
luanda ce qui est historique l'unita un
petit peu plus tôt dans la journée
avaient rejeté les résultats provisoires
donnés par la commission nationale
électorale
l'unita qui affirme avoir procédé à son
propre comptage des voix sur la base des
pv affiché devant les bureaux de vote la
cnl la commission nationale électorale
devrait donner des résultats finaux dans
les prochaines heures merci beaucoup
clément monroe merci à julie dubois qui
a qui est à vos côtés à luanda notre
envoyé spécial nos envoyés spéciaux en
angola au kenya alors que des
gouvernements élus ont commencé à prêter
serment aujourd'hui des membres de la
commission électorale se réunissaient
devant leur bureau à naïrobi pour
dénoncer les violences auxquelles ils
sont confrontés
venus de nombreuses régions différentes
ce sont eux qui organisait le scrutin du
9 août dernier et qui ont été en
première ligne lorsque des violences et
autres tentatives d'intimidation se sont
produites à nairobi la correspondance de
bassin en mieux
les agents de la commission électorale
dénonce un nombre croissant de violence
depuis le lendemain du scrutin du 9 août
dernier tous sont en tête les images de
ce qui s'est passé au centre national de
décompte des voix peu avant l'annoncé du
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
des membres du parti à imola où modja de
raïla odinga s'en sont pris aux membres
de la commission mais les violences ne
se sont pas déroulées uniquement dans
cet endroit il ya eu notamment au nord
du pays dans la région de wajir en agent
qui s'est fait tirer dessus qui en a
perdu via la jambe ailleurs ici à
nairobi l'un d'entre eux a disparu a été
kidnappée il a été retrouvé mort
plusieurs jours après après avoir été
torturé alors ils se sont réunis ce
jeudi matin pour avoir une pensée pour
leurs collègues qui sont morts ou qui
ont été blessés durant ces élections et
pour demander aussi plus de sécurité
dans leur travail écoutez les oui nous
sommes fatigués des intimidations des
politiciens nous voulons qu'ils écoutent
ce message tout des politiques en place
nous sommes aussi des humains nous ne
voulons pas être victime d'intimidation
ou de harcèlement dans les centres de
dépouillement
nous voulons dire à la classe politique
que les élections ne devraient pas être
une question de vie ou de mort
c'est une élection doit causer des morts
alors on ne peut plus appeler ça une
élection
ses membres de la commission électorale
demande à la police d'assurer leur
sécurité ils demandent aussi au bureau
du procureur d'ouvrir des enquêtes sur
toutes les formes d'abus et de violence
qui ont pu avoir lieu durant les
élections tous doivent être sévèrement
punis distille et ils sont
particulièrement inquiet car certaines
élections locales n'ont pas pu avoir
lieu le jour du scrutin le 9 août
dernier elle aurait dû avoir lieu
quelques jours après mais voilà le
président de la commission électorale
par peur de tentative de fraude et de
violences a dû les déplacés au 29 août
prochain alors tous demandent une
sécurité maximale pour leurs collègues
qui seront déployés sur place ce jour là
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous la faut
continuer sa français
[Musique]